live at noon live local now we start
here at noon a lockdown at cimarron
memorial high school finally over ccsd
says a fight involving two students one
of them with a knife prompted that
lockdown earlier this morning hector
mejia joining us live outside campus
near tonay and smoke ranch and hector
what exactly happened here
well just in the last 30 minutes we
confirmed this fight involved a knife
and right now we're currently waiting
for the clark county school district to
confirm
injuries involving those two students as
well as the extent of those injuries but
one parent out here told us at least one
of them was treated in an ambulance and
earlier this morning we captured
investigators with what appeared to be
evidence bags as parents drove up to
pick up their students here in an email
the cimarron high school principal said
one student took out a knife and
attacked another student during that
fight the principal said a school staff
member acted quickly disarming the
student and called for help
the school was placed on a hard lockdown
while police investigated we talked with
a couple of students who said there is
cell phone video of the attack
circulating online and we're told it all
happened right before 8 o'clock this
morning
the video was pretty violent they said
that there was some blood on campus like
on the quad they weren't letting anyone
in to go see it i always think about how
if anything could like go wrong like
what would be my first move for like an
emergency about my safety my family
letting them know that i'm okay
it's finals week so students were
already scheduled to get out early today
some of them had to wait for their
parents to arrive in order for them to
be able to walk out of class here we're
also told the lockdown was placed out of
an abundance of caution metro police was
also on site during part of the
investigation reporting from cimarron
high school hector mejia live local now
hectare thanks for those updates